yeah welcome to this video a new
five-minute game Gaston I am here from
this is Ukrainian who came in yeah Kings
Indian or a group felt let's say let's
try this funny h4 line that recently got
popular we shook played this against
against Carlton and down and the
candidates and got rather decent
position it was it was actually fairly
solid he took on f6 later and played age
five yeah at least that netted a couple
of seconds on the clock I don't really
know him any any lines here so do I take
now and play III or h5 probably take and
play h5 right otherwise the Sun doesn't
really make much sense
I really don't want go and see white
giving checkmate yeah maybe what
actually happens if he takes on c4 I
think we follow this grease Chaka Khan's
again i think i'm not sure what did cars
and play him i think he played Bishop f5
I'm not sure Bishop f5 looks looks a bit
strange because of taking a queen bee
three maybe it is still playable I don't
know I wonder what actually happens if
he takes the form ok didn't materialize
ok they're probably I need to take him
so what's now
hmm they're done look too bad for what I
mean 22h 67 it's a very very crude way
of fun playing
yeah crude crude or not Queen age 61 is
threatening and if he plays Bishop g7 I
list them ya cain't a bit of time what
we need to and i wonder if i should go
Quinn a form in this position gaining a
tempo in turn going for Quinn to H or
maybe Queenie 595 actually let's go
queen let's go 95 winning a temple again
and if he takes okay he's playing
without the bishop he probably I cannot
do that if I go Quinn f4 age for now
should I take on d5 before not sure yeah
let's let's speed up I'm ahead on the
clock for once and if I now spend spend
all my time it doesn't help and to age
for him this was the idea all along
okay yeah well you can't play em
probably just rupee aid and this isn't
isn't bad at all yeah do I take now all
is there some some others
the check is ohm is probably nonsense
yeah probably need to dig I'm of course
not very well developed this is this is
clear
the yarn I've got Bishop b5 threatening
after e3 so probably before he was
probably yeah this is too much I can he
can probably take it and sacrifice no
let's be content with winning a temple
here and getting getting stuff developed
so push-up d3m
yeah it's not so clear where my king is
supposed to go
my intention is night F for this yeah
yeah probably probably need to the
question is some Quincy to wear this
might be might be a problem in my play
if I fall so
okay just go look see one
and maybe I should just just care for
now okay I'm not meeting on the edge
file anyway so let's return to normal
kind of play and okay not G Queen d3m
now can I can play it but the night is
really stupid him this was probably a
bad idea
I hope I'm calculating this correctly it
takes takes B 4 B 3 I hope this is
really working Oh completely completely
overlooked dad I can just take it ah
there is you put okay maybe I can get
some counter play anyway 95 and on e6
maybe night if for a night f6 stuff like
that or 96 even hmm and maybe maybe
there's some a bit of counterclaim yeah
I thought and I thought 96 isn't a
smooth 96
I cannot cannot calculate this to the
end yeah I'm threatening all kinds of
pieces now look see one night see for
that if it moves the Queen a taxi to win
sir instantly I think he needs to go and
look down he's got a couple of dangerous
pawns oh now I got upon myself the zone
was helpful
time morning
I'm not quite sure what he is doing I
probably has bishops III at the end you
should be too coming
I wanted to play f3 this was a bad mouth
lip yeah check
check
check
check
check-check
yeah okay you should buy three is mate
yet I was I was too slow I mean I give
of course I can never lose the game just
just from position so the question is
can wide win it yeah difficult maybe
there is some some way and the computer
gives it as completely winning but it's
about 17 seconds it so it's not easy at
all d 696 d 6 wins okay yeah that
doesn't really help of course i was i
was in very bad shape losing this is of
course is just nonsense 96 and after
that lets get some gets tricky and here
needs to take with the beep on keeping a
solid structure after this it's just
just winning for white probably allow it
even allowed i allowed too much actually
but ok it's the matter of seconds yeah
this age for lives actually not so bad
it looks it looks a bit strange but it's
it's playable thanks for watching